it's time now for our seen and unseen
segment where we exposed what's behind
the big cultural stories of the day
sorry we're laughing about something
else
young Americans are developing some very
peculiar new habits and for more we're
joined by Fox News contributor York
Times bestselling author of the will
wilder series Raymond Arroyo okay
Raymond let's start with some trends
that you've picked up on among
Millennials and they might be what and
what do they tell us about the new
generation you don't want to over
generalize because there's some great
things about Millennials they're
contemplative they reuse things but
content they are there they rot and the
laptop people at Starbucks they're
willing to move they're willing to
change it and find their destiny no no
they're more poor more mobile than we
are here's what they're doing they have
adopted what's called small house
movements where they live in campers or
RVs no no or containers containers these
are little babies that they're they're
offering to them and they're also living
in pods in their parents backyards now
three-fourths from all campers are
Generation X and Millennials because
they are transient they're impermanent a
little bit but there's an interesting
thing I saw in the Los Angeles Times and
in a ton of other periodicals they are
green thumbs among the Millennial
Generation how do we go from containers
agree I'm gonna make this fit let's say
a 20-17
gardening survey found that of the six
million new gardeners in America five
million or aged 18 to 34 they're
Millennials they are cohabitating with
plants Laura because there's too much of
a commitment with a cat right exactly
they don't want to go all the way to
with a cat so I go back to the firm or a
cactus will work so they're Jackson get
off the graphic let's go back to the
houses they're jamming their apartments
with greenery because they want a sense
of connectedness you know it might my
take on this is they want something
natural in an impermanent world my
advice get a pet get a child don't get a
child you know where you gonna get that
at Costco well no no baby couldn't get
married first that's usually how it
happens but my advice don't spend your
youth on the ficus it will not give you
Mother's Day card and when you get old
it will not water you so don't do that